monsieur bernard la marge de raffinage
explose littéralement comment comment ça
s'explique
c'est la demande présentement il ya une
demande pour transformation additionnels
dans le marché de l'atlantique ça c'est
marché respectable desservir l'europe et
nous parfois où l'on achète un peu là
aussi c'est demain pour des raisons
commerciales et aussi les états unis
mais évidemment il ya une demande
additionnelle qui vient de de l'europe
sur ce marché et ont crié un gain
donc c'est lié à la guerre annuel dans
ce marché donc c'est la guerre en
ukraine qui fait cette pression-là sur
la demande où est plus l'économie
mondiale sont toutes vos billets on a
des appréhensions
présente à l'économie mondiale vos biens
en les prix des matières premières est
très élevé ce qui est à dire qu elle le
demande lui-même factures sont en pleine
opération
donc ce n
est donc qu au québec au canada mais au
québec particulièrement nous sommes liés
à ce marché nord américain est-ce qu'on
pourrait déterminer nos prix autrement
est ce que notre capacité de raffinage
ici est suffisante au québec au québec
on est un peu plus costaud suffisants
c'est à dire que la capacité de l'odorat
céneri le seul corps révélées roch à
québec je crois que j delors les deux
sens et de l'aude à peu près 400 villes
baril par jour et on consomme moins que
je crois que c'est de l'ordre de 350
dont nous en export on exporte
principalement vers les marchés voisins
immédiats comme ottawa et le nord de
l'essonne lui a donc ça c'est des
marchés ouverts il n'y a pas de relaxe
et mérite donc on est en compétition
avec des grossistes de deux de ses
régions lors qu'ils achètent du pétrole
qui rend presse palma dans le port de
new york
nous en gérait les marges de raffinerie
dans chez nous là et dans le sud de
l'ontario
sont à peu près les mêmes que l'on
retrouve pour ce qui est payé dalle part
de new york une raison si kate au nord
de new york et dans l'état de la
nouvelle angleterre il ya aucune
raffinerie donc c'est des gens
l'achètent où les prix sont les plus bas
pire nous on est dans ce marché je le
dis quand on voit l'augmentation des
marges des raffineurs
l'augmentation des marges des raffineurs
c'est le cas aussi pour son corps à
montréal et pour valero à lévis oui qui
suivent ce qui se passe dans le port de
new york ouais qu'est-ce qui se
passerait par exemple s'ils ont décidé
au québec de limiter le prix de
l'essence comme le propose le parti
québécois à 1 $ 60 en dix ans ben les
les les pétrolières vont absorber le
manque à gagner en quelque sorte parce
qu'elles sont tellement riches est ce
qu'on pourrait faire ça et quelles
conséquences aurait pourquoi confond les
plus tard hier avec des de chéri tu es
là pas du tout donc ici si on ne paient
pas le prix mondial du pétrole revenu
mondial
hier était
114 dollars
dans ces eaux là c'est à peu près le
même prix partout d'allemand alors si on
ne paie pas ce prix là il y aura près
puis pétrole qui sera livré et il y aura
pénurie c'est tout évidemment pourquoi
juger il faudrait subventionner l'achat
du pétrole comme on avait fait dire à la
politique énergétique nationale 2 lors
du premier choc pétrolier de santé
réalisé 69
donc c'est ce qu'on avait fait et ça
avait été désastreux parce que d'un côté
on importait du pétrole dans les six 6
comment on fait assez régulièrement et
on exportait dans l'ouest alors
évidemment si on importe au plus mondial
mais on vend à un prix inférieur russie
mais il fallait le subventionner
monsieur trudeau avait eu le don fait
avait eu l'idée de taxer le pétrole
exporté par l'alberta pour payer pour le
mcg a gardé des raffineries dans ls donc
ça c'était complètement désastreux
économie et sur le plan politique très
bien monsieur bernard merci pour cette
explication ce soir bonne soirée
quand monsieur st pierre plamondon dit
qu'on devrait exiger des compagnies
pétrolières de réduire leurs profits
c'est pas sérieux c'est pas sérieux du
projet par une méthode là dessus le mais
le pétrole d'un prix mondial peut pas
penser que nous au québec on indique
très le prix aux sociétés pétrolières
avec nous ce soir pas st pierre
plamondon le chef du parti québécois
bonsoir bonsoir plafonné à 1 $ 60 le
prix de l'essence c'est pas sérieux dit
le premier ministre du québec dit que
c'est pas réaliste
est-ce que c'est réaliste pour vous et
comment on pourrait rendre ce réaliste
non seulement c'est sérieux mais c'est
absolument nécessaire pour une période
de temps limitée vu l'urgence de la
situation sur le plan de l'inflation
évidemment comme disait le professeur il
ya quelques instants le québec n'a pas
le pouvoir sur le prix du baril de
pétrole maintenant comme votre émission
d'hier l'a démontré très clairement il
ya quelque chose d'anormal qui se passe
sur le plan de la marge pour les
raffineries ce qu'ils étaient huit neuf
scènes de profits sur un litre est
devenu 48 49 cents de profits et ça je
suis surpris que le professeur ne
mentionne pas c'est le fruit d'un
oligopole on est dans un environnement
où il n'ya pas de concurrence on appelle
ça un cartel dans un cartel ces
compagnies-là n'hésite pas à fixer leurs
prix et à ambitionner sur les profits et
lorsqu'il ya pas de concurrence dans un
marché mais une des alternatives on l'a
vu avec hydro québec qui est également
un monopole c'est d'impliquer la régie
de l'énergie pour exercer une
surveillance nous on propose sur une
base temporaire des surveillances partie
de la baisse si ce que claude boeuf
claude béchard avait tenté proposé de
faire en 2007 le projet de loi n'a pas
vu le jour mais c'est ce que la loi
française permet si ce que présentement
le portugal l'espagne le luxembourg et
la belgique à des degrés divers fonds de
manière à exercer un contrôle sur ce qui
normalement devrait aller de soi en
raison d'une concurrence mais vu qu'un
cartel il ya une volonté de avoir un
contrôle gouvernemental sur les marges
de profit dans ce que s'il vous l'avez
démontré hier ce qui cloche c'est le 49
cents de marge de profit au coulis
raffinerie pas justifiable plafonner le
prix sans compensation est ce que est ce
que c est ce que c'est possible de faire
ça les entreprises les pétrolières se
sont des entreprises privées bien sûr la
demande est au rendez-vous loffredo
rendez vous on
dicton pas comme dit le premier ministre
les marchés du pétrole dans le monde
sans compensation vous pensez vraiment
que les pétrolières vont continuer
d'alimenter un marché où il se verrait
offrir un prix qui serait franchement
plus bas que le prix mondial
présentement non c'est ça on n'ira
jamais en bas du prix du baril de
pétrole mais ensuite on va demander à la
régie de l'énergie de regarder les
marges au niveau de la raffinerie on
parlait de valero en parler de délire à
faire au niveau du détaillant et à ce
moment là évidemment qu'on va fixer le
prix plafond le gel du prix vont être en
fonction de maintenir une marge de
profit acceptable quelque chose comme
vous avez présenté hier en 2008 900 mais
on va dire aux raffineries la 48 cents
c'est du vol qualifié c'est une forme de
fraude qui découlent de mes positions
mais les réalités vont vous donner
pouvait compter ailleurs dans ce cas là
parce que le nord-est américain n'est
pas un marché bien muni en référé valero
pourrait dire vous voulez pas me donner
mon prix que je demande je veux exporter
vers le nord-est américain oui mais en
mettant fin aux pénuries de produits
raffinés non parce qu'elles se sont des
compagnies qui opèrent sur notre
territoire est là si on abdique 9 droit
de réglementer les prix de réglementer
ces entreprises là qui opèrent à lévis
si on abdique complètement le droit des
gouvernements de veiller à ce qu'on soit
dans une économie de concurrence et non
pas une économie de d'oligopole qui
vraiment siphonne les économies de nos
familles des longtemps très d'abdiquer
sur la démocratie donc va falloir donner
sur une base temporaire un mandat la
régie de l'énergie et surtout se
débarrasser pour toujours du pétrole
c'est à dire offrir des voitures
électriques au moins doubler l'offre par
voie de cauter il va falloir également
se doter de transport collectif faut que
l'offre de transport collectif soit
nettement augmenté changez l'urbanisme
donc nous aux prochaines élections on va
faire campagne sur larguer les
pétrolières pour toujours mais bale et
lennon rechercher les prix de l'essence
pointer plamondon c'est de stimuler la
demande pour les prix de l'essence c'est
contre productif sur le plan
environnemental si vous faites ça si on
le fait à court terme ici on le fait
dans des termes comme un noeud une et 60
ou c'est pas un prix pas cher c'est pas
un incitatif la vérité c'est que le
consommateur québécois en ce moment il
n'a pas l'alternative de l'achat d'un
véhicule et les rick et il a une oeuvre
de transport collectif très limité donc
où peut-il aller à par s'appauvrir
devant un gouvernement qui gardent les
bras croisés et regardant la situation
est pire notre gouvernement ce moment sa
réaction c'est d'imprimer à même les
fonds publics à même nos taxes et nos
impôts des compensations pour le
consommateur mais on sait très bien que
cet argent le voit directement dans la
poche des pétrolières alors que donc
nous on dit règlement ton comme on le
fait pour hydro québec et dans le cas de
d'autres monopole sur une base
temporaire mais surtout de noms des
alternatives aux québécoises et
québécois pour qu'on largue qu'on sorte
du un troll porto jour ne plus être
dépendant de ces compagnies merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous donc les
pouvoirs nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit